I want to say thank you from the bottom
of my heart to you members of the
Academy uh to you RV not only because we
received tonight the award that any
filmmaker would ever dream to receive
but because you're offering me tonight
the opportunity to pay tribute to
remember this Academy that I miss so
much
the Oscar winner Claud Bailey and he
directed movies like the two of us Jean
de florette and produced in world with
directors such as Francis Ford Coppola
Milosh Foreman Pedro almodóvar Roman
Polanski and I always start and remember
will I ever one day be able to work with
such director a director that could
stand in front of this example and
tonight I know I do because I am the
producer of machetes and injures and I
am glad to be as producer okay thank you
iid like to say very very important
things hmm I want to say hi to my kids
and it's 6:00 in the morning in Paris so
you should go to bed in 30 seconds I
want to say to my wife Berenice Bejo was
here that I love you but it's not just
that it's about the movie you're
inspired the movie and you're the the
soul of the movie and the positive
feeling of the movie thank you for being
this in the movie and in my life and I
want to thank three percent I want to
thank Billy Wilder
I want to thank Billy Wilder and I want
to thank Billy Wilder thank you very
much
[Applause]